weeds no problem kill weeds and grasses
roots and all with a shot of Roundup for
drivers patternless fences make weeding
easy with Roundup nothing kills weeds
better over the years our hospitals and
courts have witnessed some major public
health scandals tobacco and asbestos
being two of the largest and most
enduring well right now a new storm is
emerging and Incredibly the culprit may
just be sitting on a shelf in your
backyard shed but the herbicide
glyphosate the main ingredient in weed
killer Roundup probably causes cancer a
California man dying of cancer just
appeared in court claiming a popular
weed killer made him sick the California
jury awarded nearly 300 million dollars
to a former School groundskeeper who
sued Monsanto claiming it's weed killers
including Roundup gave him Non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma created by chemical giant
Monsanto Roundup is the most widely used
weed killer on Earth sprayed on
everything from Gardens footpaths to
fields of crops it is quite simply
everywhere in August a landmark court
case blew wide open the question of
whether monsanto's
he was using a sort of a pressure hose
sprayer so he was spraying 150 gallons
every morning and so he his exposure was
pretty extreme and prior to his exposure
his skin was perfect he was healthy he
had no other chemical exposures but
within two years after starting this
sort of massive spraying he developed
this incredibly aggressive cancer that
you know ultimately is going to take his
life
thank you
in July 2001 our family took a vacation
we ended up eating three hamburgers
before he got sick we started to see
blood in Kevin's diarrhea so we took him
to the emergency room and they said
kidneys were starting to fail to watch
this beautiful child go from being
perfectly healthy to dead in 12 days
that this could happen from eating food
cut fruit cut cantaloupe strawberries
caramel apples tomatoes onions chicken
all these products are likely
contaminant I ate a salad and now I have
long-term health effects from it
Monsanto is the world leader in
biotechnology ninety percent of the GMOs
grown on the planet belong to them in
Europe only five percent of the food is
genetically modified here it's 70
percent since welcoming Agro giant
Monsanto into the country in 1996
Argentina has become the world's largest
soybean producer today nearly 100
percent of its soy crop is genetically
altered genetically modded GMO stands
for genetically modified organism
basically what it is is food made in a
laboratory until the last 20 or 30 years
this is food that has never existed
before in humanity so it's made in a
laboratory and more often than not
they're inserting viruses or bacteria
into these plants most of them have been
genetically modified to resist the
application of Roundup like Roundup
Ready soybeans in that they create a
seed that is resistant to the types of
chemicals that they want to apply to
them so for example Roundup Ready corn
is resistant to Roundup which is the
chemical that goes on it or glyphosate
which is actually called that corn
all over it and it will do nothing to it
everything dies except the Roundup Ready
corn close to 100 of conventional
farmers use Roundup to some extent it's
essential we don't have an alternative
to glyphosate in the system at the
moment monsanto's GMOs have inundated
the world principally in North and South
America Asia and Australia after only 10
years transgenic crops Now cover 250
million Acres since 1974 we've put on
1.6 billion kilograms more than 3.5
billion pounds on crops in the United
States alone it's on 70 different food
crops including corn soy canola wheat so
if you eat a slice of bread a bowl of
Cheerios a sushi roll a plate of pasta
slice of pizza chicken nugget Cheerios
have more glyphosate per serving than
vitamin d and vitamin B12
renowned scientists lost job when he
warned about e-foods we were dismissed
for Disobedience they fired us the last
20 or 30 years Monsanto has engaged in a
systematic and deliberate campaign to
attack any science that says their
product is not safe and to attack any
scientist that has the courage to say
something they have a corporate culture
that has zero interest in safety and has
an only an interest in maintaining the
ability of them to sell this product it
is the safest herbicide that's ever been
developed it has just been an amazing
amazing record of not just productivity
and use but also the extent to which it
has been examined and scrutinized and
studied over 40 years Roundup was always
marketed as incredibly safe as so much
safer than any other herbicide on the
market you know some of the early sales
people would say ah it's safe enough to
drink safer than table salt you can
drink a whole cord of it and it won't
hurt you you want to drink some we have
some here I'd be happy to actually but
not not really but if you say so I have
some questions I'm not stupid tell the
truth it's not dangerous in humans no
it's not so are you ready to drink one
glass of no I'm not an idiot I'm not an
idiot if you go down the history of the
sort of really bad chemicals pesticides
in U.S society or even world society
every single one of them has its origins
in Monsanto I mean the last 150 years
whether it be DDT pcbs agent orange
dioxin I mean Monsanto has been behind
all of those Monsanto has effectively
made a business out of poisoning people
and getting away with it if my life or a
Superman comic Monsanto of Alex Luther
so you're in one Santo in the early
1970s and you've run into a little
problem the key ingredient in your
Flagship product agent orange had just
been banned yeah that agent orange which
meant you were left looking for a new
bestseller enter glyphosates glyphosate
it was originally developed as a tank
scaleant so to scale the calcium and
other deposits metal deposits rust
deposits from the inside of you know
underground tanks and in 1973 Monsanto
had to stop producing DBT that was his
Flagship product it needed another
product and I figured out that
glyphosate somebody at some point
apparently threw some glyphosate on that
you know out in the back in the yard and
everything like green died where they
touched him and so somebody said oh this
will be a good herbicide because it
kills all plants thanks to glyphosate
you were able to create Roundup the
environmentally friendly agent orange
originally Monsanto developed it as a
herbicide but the way that it was
applied initially from 1973 to 1993 was
in backpack sprayers so guys would walk
down the cornfield cornrows early in the
season when the corn was competing with
nearby weeds for sunlight and they would
shoot the individual weeds then in 93
somebody figured out a way that
glyphosate there was certain bacteria
that glyphosate would not kill and they
said we could take a gene out of that
bacteria and put it into a corn seed and
develop a corn that cannot be killed by
glyphosate so they developed a Roundup
Ready corn and that corn you could pork
glyphosate all over it and it will do
nothing to it and within just a few
short years you had gone from selling a
powerful weed killer to selling a weed
killer and weed killer resistant seeds
for crops like corn and soy so now you
could fire all of those workers who were
expensive and you hire one airplane and
they fly over the fields they saturate
the entire landscape with glyphosate
everything dies except the Roundup Ready
corn soon Round Up herbicide and Roundup
Ready seeds took over the markets even
if Farmers didn't want to plant these
GMO corn seeds if neighboring Farms were
using Roundup that Roundup would blow
right over to their Farms killing their
crops forcing them to buy random
produces from you even if they didn't
want to for saves that are owned by
Monsanto are there for one purpose and
one purpose only to rise raise the cost
of food you had completely monopolized
the corn and soy industry the United
States is already the world leader in
biotechnology and we want to keep it
that way in 1991 alone it was a four
billion dollar industry it should reach
at least 50 billion dollars by the year
2000 as long as we resist the spread
unnecessary regulations
unnecessary regulation and even though
reports started coming out about how
toxic Roundup was to humans you didn't
care there's many many diseases that are
linked to glyphosate exposure including
non-alcoholic fatty liver cancers are
very very closely linked a lot of kidney
diseases and then severe damage to the
microbiome dream education in the U.S
Virgin Islands turned into a nightmare
for one Delaware family apparently over
time the family was found in their Villa
on Saint John Island and the father was
in a coma and the two boys and the mom
were suffering from severe seizures EPA
officials say a pesticide at their
rented luxury Villa may be to blame the
ground up as caused your cancer yes I am
convinced because this kills people out
there too not only me do you think it's
killing but yes it is killing people out
there then they should know that this
product is not really safe to use in the
1970s Monsanto used a company called
industrial biotech Laboratories to test
Roundup to get it registered with the
U.S regulator the Environmental
Protection Agency the EPA the lab was
caught up in a fraud Scandal it was
found that this laboratory was actually
just doctoring a lot of the numbers the
sort of cooking the books so to speak on
these safety studies and our Regulators
in the U.S went in and did an
investigation and found out you know how
fraudulent these studies actually were
and they based that on a study a mouse
study where the 70 or 80 percent of the
mice got Guinea tumors you add another
they brought a Monsanto and we got all
of these internal arguments from the
Monsanto that show they were going to
pay this I had just a huge amount of
money coming to dispute those findings
any EPA let them reopen the test and he
came in and claimed that he found tumors
in the control groups but he never show
those tumors to anybody they threw out
the study and they said and Monsanto had
to promise to redo the study and in 40
years it never redone it the whole thing
was based on fraud from the outset until
eventually in the 19 early 1990s the EPA
decided to just go along with Monsanto
and overrule its own toxicologist and in
the final decision in which EPA
determined they would classify
glyphosate as not likely to be
carcinogenic some of their own
scientists refused to sign off on that
but despite those claims the
manufacturer is still insisting their
product is completely safe and has no
links whatsoever to any cancer after the
the Court verdict the company's vice
president Scott Partridge released this
statement claiming more than 800
scientific studies and reviews support
the fact that glyphosate does not cause
cancer to the 800 studies all relate to
cancer or do they relate to other
potential illnesses all types of risks
and Hazards and diseases a wide wide
variety which were required to do when
we obtain registrations from governments
around the world they don't simply ask
you does it cause cancer or not want to
know all aspects of health and safety
related to the product they had a guy
called Jasper on it was out of the
pesticide division was that a note to
Monsanto saying I'm gonna kill this
study by the atsdr I'm going to pressure
them to kill the study and when I do
that you guys need to give me a medal oh
we have that email and the judge
wouldn't let us show the email to the
jury why you know they the judges are
funny you know we thought it was
relevant but the judge it was too
prejudicial we gotta hold through the
discovery of communication
from the White House that showed that
President Trump had sent during the
trial message to leadership of Monsanto
is saying we have got your back and that
basically is the way that EPA has been
behaving EPA even before Trump was
working hand in hand with Monsanto for
many years the AG committees in the
house of Senate are highly funded and
the members are highly funded by right
agricultural committees the chair of
those committees will always be the
biggest receiver you know of chemical
and big AG is going to be Cargill and
Smithfield and Monsanto who are paying
that guy is millions and millions of
dollars over the career at that
politician and he's bought this old and
owned he is a sock puppet for the
companies everybody else in the vision
is working for him they take his lead
because their salaries will depend on
him he knows that he's preparing the
groundwork so that he can have a soft
line landing at Monsanto or wherever
else he needs to do them a bunch of
favors while he's still in office there
and then on the 20th year he can go over
and work for the company but everybody
in that agency is being schooled in that
oh you know the whistleblowers get
weeded out and they get sent to offices
in Dubuque and where they can't cause
any problems as Monsanto in the early
1990s you were rolling in money wasn't
enough with a rap sheet like that you
would think your urged for poisoning
people to get rich from it would be
satisfied but no you had to take it one
step further and by the early 2000s you
had discovered something new something
that would bring Roundup to not just soy
and corn but to everything we eat pasta
bread pizza cereal even oats have been
contaminated to where today glyphosate
this incredibly dangerous cancer-causing
chemical has been found in 80 percent of
the US population yes you watching this
right now probably have life saving you
especially if you're eating the standard
American diets nutrition in the
microbiome was a huge piece of why
cancer was happening in the human being
to begin with we have done something to
our food chain we have done something
fundamental to our environment that
would lead to this massive reversal of
Public Health in this country and so we
took the glyphosate spraying Maps but
interestingly they don't superimpose on
our cancer death Maps until you pull in
the tributaries of the Mississippi River
and you suddenly realize that we're
collecting some 80 85 percent of all the
glyphosates sprayed in the United States
into a single water system and
glyphosate is unique that it's a
water-soluble toxin which means it's
going to travel through this whole water
cycle that would move through the
ecosystem and now you start looking at
the stories that are coming out of the
Dead Zone in the ocean at the end of the
Mississippi River it's now the size of
Rhode Island and you get we're getting
these massive devastating algae blooms
in the lakes in the midwest all the way
up towards Canada and it's killing the
fish life 75 percent of the rainfall in
the south is now contaminated with
glyphosate 75 of the air we breathe
contaminated with glyphosate and we're
becoming a very unresilient and damaged
species where our fertility is dropping
one in three males in the United States
now infertile one in four women so as
fertility drops disease Rises children
get sick we move from four percent of
the entire U.S population with chronic
disease in the 1960s to 46 percent of
our children with a chronic disease now
in 2018 here stay dangerous and this is
how Monsanto poisoned the world we will
depend government for MC negro any
property grow if they control C they
control food they know it it's strategic
it's more powerful than bombs it's more
powerful than guns and I'll never forget
he didn't want to beat and he said we
just paid three billion dollars for
these television stations we'll tell you
what the news is when it comes to the
media rate really it's not just the
parent companies it's also your
corporate sponsors it's also people that
are putting out the ads I mean Monsanto
had this story actually aired would have
probably pulled their advertisement for
Roundup for uh aspartame and all those
other products that again aren't tested
but advertise all over all over Fox News
the reporters they actually counter suit
against Fox under Florida's
whistleblower statute and as it turns
out under Florida law they lost that
lawsuit because it turns out it's not
illegal to falsify the news you know
I've got a soybean in my hand here and
I can eat the soybean it's very safe
give it a try
if you're like me and you spent most of
your life eating all this terrible food
that shouldn't even be allowed to be
called food because you didn't know any
better until now then like me your gut
microbiome is probably wrecked inside
your gut is a whole ecosystem of good
bacteria that helps break down food
while also regulating your hormones and
mood eating artificial Foods severely
damages your microbiome which can lead
to literal depression and a ton of other
horrible things like obesity and cancer
thankfully it is possible to fix your
microbiome which is why you gotta check
out Koso and Japan Koso is the name for
a traditional fermented enzyme drink
that people typically drink for cleanses
this Coastal drink took that ancient
tradition and made it into the only 100
natural supplement on the market that
has been clinically proven to improve
your gut health because of all the
probiotics prebiotics post biotics and
enzymes in its and this stuff actually
tastes great
it tastes like a sweet juice but it also
has an herbal flavor too it's really
enjoyable I take the stuff every day I
love how it really wakes me up in the
morning it's got over 500 reviews from
verified buyers many have lost weight
and improved their skin because of it
the ingredient list is filled with 100
plus vegetables fruit seaweeds and
mushrooms that have been fermented for a
whole year it's non-GMO and made in
Japan and all you got to do is take one
tablespoon a day and you're good highly
recommended so scroll down and click the
link below or use code Jake 15 to get 15
off scroll down and click the link below
now thanks to RS kosov for sponsoring
this video
foreign
up was always designed to be used early
in the season so it could kill weeds and
then it would get washed away by the
rain and then in 2000 around 2006 they
discovered that if you sprayed it on
wheat late in the season it would
desiccate the wheat in other words it
would dry it out and one of the big
losses for Farmers is wheat is if it
rains during the harvest season you
can't Harvest it because it gets moldy
and so if you can spray a desk in on it
and dries it out and kills it you can
Harvest it right away and it won't get
moldy so suddenly Ronald was being used
throughout the season instead of just in
the beginning whenever farmers were
worried that their wheat peas canola
soybean lentils arrived were at risk of
not drying out or getting moldy they
would spray the fully grown crops with
Roundup to dry them out Farmers would
coat their crops around up as close to
us just three days before harvesting
them which meant unlike when they were
spraying it early in the season that
Roundup was not being washed off by the
rain all these crops that were being
harvested for you and I to eat was still
completely covered in toxic Roundup so
all the wheat in our country started
being sprayed that year in 2006 with
glyphosate and that's the year you saw
this explosion of celiac diseases and uh
you know gluten allergies and all of
this stuff so if you were making
billions before you couldn't even count
your riches now you are taking Roundup
to a whole new level and life could not
be any better but there was just one
tiny problem people were starting to ask
questions about the to round up on their
health and researchers were starting to
connect the dots between Roundup and a
long list of deadly diseases people in
regular contact with the product we're
getting so if you wanted to protect your
product reputation and money you would
have to find a way to cover up the truth
and fast
foreign
[Music]
to you glyphosate poses zero risk to
humans one used according to the label
instructions so let's take a closer look
at what the Roundup label actually says
harmful if swallows or inhaled but it's
fine to spray crops with it right before
it's harvested that's because even
though the Roundup label clearly says
Roundup and glyphosate is toxic you've
done such a great job at marketing it as
safe and biodegradable that farmers
believe it even if it's not true and
this was a very intentional effort over
the years you've paid scientists to
ghost write research papers that claim
glyphosate is safe when it really isn't
you've also pay scientists to contradict
papers that say glyphosate is dangerous
you've even planted fake journalists to
push the media into believing your
narrative on glyphosates quote we
recently learned that a young woman
falsely posing as a freelance BBC
reporter at one of the Roundup cancer
trials was in fact a reputation
management consulting for FTI Consulting
whose clients include Monsanto the woman
spent time with journalists who were
covering the Hardman V Monsanto trial in
San Francisco pretending to do reporting
while also suggesting to real reporter
certain story lines or points that favor
Monsanto End quotes and you even made
sure your Executives buddy up with The
Regulators who are supposed to oversee
your products which might be the reason
why the FDA refuses to test the levels
of glyphosate in products like oat and
whis and thanks to this all-out
marketing War you managed to fool the
world into thinking that Roundup really
isn't all that bad for you and will
Roundup and glyphosate as the last thing
on consumers mind when they shopped the
flood gates were opened and millions of
Roundup contaminated products began to
flood the supermarket aisles
[Music]
by the late 2000s farmers were spraying
Roundup on anything they needed to dry
quickly wait lentils canola Millet oats
peas even Rye was dried using Roundup
which meant that not even wheat-free rye
bread or pasta was safe in 2018
independent researchers tested common
Supermarket products for glyphosate
contamination and the results they found
were shocking Kellogg's Frosted Flakes
Kellogg's all brand buds General Mills
weak Chucks Mueller's Penny pasta and
dozens of other Pizza crackers and oat
products in America and Canada contain
significant amounts of glyphosates it
wasn't just corn and soy anymore it was
almost everything you could find at your
local supermarkets people everywhere
were being poisoned by your toxic
herbicide and even though you have been
making Bank off of Roundup for years the
walls were slowly starting to close in
slowly people were connecting the dust
to all the diseases associated with
Roundup contaminated food so it was time
for you to pack your bags and get out
while you still could
[Music]
foreign
official Germany's buyer is now the
world's biggest agricultural chemicals
and seeds maker at softwick closed the
purchase of U.S rival Monsanto on
Thursday in June 2018 a German big
Pharma and chemical company called bear
bought Monsanto for 63 billion dollars
it was a huge acquisition and bear that
they were acquiring an agricultural Cash
Cow because by then Roundup had become
the most widely used herbicide in
America and they were able to buy the
entire company for just 63 billion
dollars it was a steal or so they
thought because oh boy they were in for
a surprise Friday a jury in San
Francisco found biochemical giant
Monsanto liable for former School
groundskeeper Dwayne Johnson's cancer
because just weeks after Bears big when
acquiring Monsanto Monsanto lost its
first Landmark lawsuit claiming that
Roundup does indeed cause cancer but
luckily bear just bought you out so you
didn't have to pay the 190 million
dollars in Damages for that or for the
two losses that followed
problem anymore it was bears and guess
what since then 18 400 other lawsuits
have been filed against Monsanto but
again not your problem you had made
billions poisoning the world's food
supply with Roundup but because you got
out just in time you get to walk away
scot-free without a dime coming out of
your pockets and there even though
they're still convinced their clothes
that ran up is totally safe this has
gone down in history as one of the worst
corporate deals ever
and you want to know how they're trying
to poison you next lab grown Meats
that's right two companies just got
approved by the good old FDA to sell
lab-grown chicken meat to a restaurant
near you and these two companies alone
are loaded with nearly a billion dollars
in funding all to convince you that
their artificial meat is just as healthy
for you as real meats and better for the
environments when in reality that could
not be further from the truth lab grown
meat is going to be horrible for you
it's filled with antibiotics cancer
cells and a bunch of other terrible
things they don't want you to know about
and we expose it all in our newest video
and our other Channel evil food supply
that you can watch right now by clicking
the card on the screen click the card on
the screen to watch now
thank you